[Music]
society-wide
people are becoming evermore tribal and
tribalism is as old as social groups
which is older than humans so it's no
surprise that people are looking to find
those who sound the most like them and
whom they imagine will be the most
likely to keep them in their heads when
things go wrong but the way that it's
manifesting is a particularly modern
instantiation that I don't think we've
seen before so you know protest is old
and is honorable
and is important we must be allowed in
any system that calls itself Democratic
to do dissent increasingly we have we
have groups who are claiming to be
emerging from this this age-old culture
of protest who are actually tamping out
dissent who are saying there are things
that cannot be said there are things
that cannot be thought there are
research programs that cannot be done
and that's dangerous and it comes from a
place of fear that fear is very powerful
evolutionarily it it rises the top of
the emotions when it shows up and it's
hard to get through the fear with an
argument that is rational right emotion
and rationality don't tend to interface
with one another very well and some of
the language that we're hearing from
from the extremes on both sides of the
political spectrum I'm not sure that
calling it a spectrum is really apt but
everyone's familiar with it so the
extremes on the right and on the left
are both using fear to further polarize
people and you know I the people on the
right are easy the people on the far
right the extremists on the right are
both I think a smaller group and better
armed
thus in some ways more terrifying but
there are so many fewer of them that
they don't seem to have as much voice in
society as the growing numbers of
extremists on the left who are using
words and increasingly in the case of
some of the the group's violent tactics
but they don't they don't tend to be
armed and the way the extreme right is
and so it's easy for people to imagine
that I was dangerous but shutting down
dissent shutting down the ability to
discuss ideas is actually the beginning
of the death of democracy so why does it
work it works because since people have
been social which is to say since before
people were people since since we were
great apes and before that primates that
weren't great apes and whatever social
mammals came before that we have been
splintering into groups and watching out
for our own and it wasn't just kin
groups it was kin groups and extended
family and then friends and family but
the tribes that we see forming now are
able to are able to garner more power
because they can use modern technology
to to move into old old circuits so
social media can be used to mobilize a
group and to enrage a group to inflame a
group where you know a town crier you
know 500 years ago or a roving
storyteller thousands of years ago might
have brought news that would have
alarmed a group of townspeople or a
village or a hunter-gatherer tribe when
they came together in their annual
fusion event with with lots and lots of
tribes together they might hear
something that struck them as dangerous
but things didn't change at the right
that they are now and so what we have
now is a rate of change that is
unprecedented in concert with these
endocrine systems all of which are
evolutionary that are so old that they
that we are we're chasing it's been said
before by many people were chasing
dopamine we're chasing serotonin we're
chasing hits of that feels good now I
feel like I'm in now I feel like I'm
part of the group and everyone else is
an enemy and it's it's dangerous
precisely because we are we are global
now we're a global society where we are
global species and we need to be
thinking and acting globally because
there's not going to be a local solution
to climate change for instance there's
not going to be a global solution to
nuclear escalation so our very personal
very individual very much evolved
responses to oh that feels good I want
to be on the end and that requires an
out means that we have increasing
polarization and people who are opposed
to each other in this increasingly
tribalistic
culture cannot find a way to converse to
come together and say you know what
actually that which unites us is greater
than that which divides us and that's
what we need right now we can do that
too there's an there's there is as long
a history almost as long in history of
cooperation in evolution as there is of
conflict the evolution of cooperation is
long and complex and and beautiful and
we somehow we need to try to enhance our
ability to find the desire to sit down
with people who don't sound like us and
it takes I think it takes meet space I
think it takes being in real time with
one another because when you do 200 80
characters on Twitter or some other post
where you're sending it out to people
most of whom you've never met all they
have to go on is those pixels in front
of them and so they respond in real-time
and come to a judgment and are
off-again whereas when you sit down with
someone whether it's for 15 minutes or
better for an hour or a day or a week
spent time in the field together you
come to see that everyone is flawed
everyone doesn't feel about some things
the way you do even if you're an
ideologue even if you think you both
bought the same ideology at the store
and you're in total agreement you
actually will find that you have
disagreements and that those
disagreements are where the juicy stuff
is like that's that is where it becomes
interesting to talk to people and that
is where you find actually the common
humanity so there's an evolutionary
basis to find into common humanity as
well but somehow we have to trick the
the algorithms well we have to trick
ourselves into not falling prey to the
algorithms that are being fed to us by
an ever-more technology technological
culture
[Music]
you